Kaya Gerber and Austin Butler are
soaking up the sun and the last few
moments of 2022. I'm not complaining the
couple was spotted in Cabo San Lucas
ahead of the new year that was really
special that's the Elvis star rocking a
Navy baseball hat a light blue t-shirt
and shorts while the model looked Beach
chic in Shades a green bikini top and a
maxi skirt also in attendance Kaya's mom
Cindy Crawford her dad Randy Gerber and
her brother Presley Gerber as your kid
gets older as you know it does get
better and better because even though
you might miss the little snuggly thing
you see them become like this person in
your life in awe Kaya's famous fam
vacations in Cabo a lot like a lot a lot
in fact back in 2020 she brought her
then-boyfriend Jacob alordi South of the
Border it's pretty amazing as for Austin
and Kaya the couple first sparked
romance rumors last December with a sore
course telling E.T at the time that the
two were seeing each other adding quote
they are getting to know each other
better and having a lot of fun hanging
out the source noted that they are very
sweet and affectionate with each other
and it feels comfortable between them
fast forward a few months and it didn't
take long for the lovebirds to go public
with their relationship Kaia and Austin
made things red carpet official in May
at the 2022 Met Gala where they were
snapped looking cozy and in love later
that month the duo packed on the PDA at
the world premiere of Austin's flick
Elvis during the 2022 Cannes Film
Festival
know you wondering
Elvis is so loved and so iconic you feel
you feel responsibility playing any
human that has actually lived but with
him it's it's like it's it's a weight
like I never felt before okay and
there's a responsibility to his family
and also putting his story into context
and while they may not shy away from
walking a red carpet together they've
kept pretty quiet about their romance
back in September Kaya celebrated her
21st birthday with a star-studded party
in LA with guests like Billy eilish Evan
Ross Madison Beer and Paris Jackson
noticeably absent Austin A source told
E.T at the time that the actor was
supposed to attend but couldn't make it
last minute but according to the source
Kaya didn't seem bothered by it at all
and was having an amazing time so
whether they're rocking the red carpet
or relaxing on vacay one thing's for
sure these two make love look good
[Music]
thank you